[Music]  back on his feet with a visible scrape  on his elbow today with the first  sighting of the 57 year old in the two  days that says terrifying scooter  accident in Italy seen here leaving the  island of Sardinia on a private plane  George Woolf with the support of an  assistant and his wife a mall  she was also holding their one-year-old  twin Ella once the couple gets to the  plane it appears George needs to brace  himself on the staircase rail before  making the climb up it's reported their  destination is Rome where filming on his  Hulu limited series catch-22 will  continue a source tells ET that George's  injury won't impact production  [Music]